there is believe it or not a playbook
for what russian president vladimir
putin's troops are doing right now in
ukraine it's a playbook written during
the long civil war in syria where putin
used russia's military might to attack
civilian targets the russians intervened
to support syria's president who remains
in power senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge has the
very first tv interview in the u.s with
an eyewitness to alleged war crimes in
syria it can get worse catherine good
morning
good morning tony our investigative team
spoke exclusively with syrian refugees
who witnessed crimes against humanity
and they fear for the people of ukraine
because they know what the russian
president did in their country as a
warning the report is graphic it may be
upsetting to some people
russia's stepped up attacks on civilians
in ukraine are now called war crimes by
the state department and president biden
says responsibility lies with vladimir
putin the devastation
that is occurring at the hands of a man
who
i quite frankly think is a war criminal
the bombing of this maternity hospital
in mariopol is not the first time
russian forces have targeted the most
vulnerable vladimir putin used the same
playbook in syria nearly a decade ago to
keep president bashar al-assad a
long-time ally also accused of war
crimes in power well i think we have to
recognize that the critical role that
russia played in the crimes committed by
the assad regime and the crimes so
horrendous that the u.n stopped counting
the debt at 400 000
seven years ago stephen rapp a former
u.s ambassador at large for war crimes
told us putin's air campaign in 2016
kept assad in control when it looked
like assad was going to be overthrown by
his own people the russians came all in
and joined in the bombardment of
hospitals and civilian neighborhoods and
now a new syrian witness has come
forward earlier this month on capitol
hill he shared his firsthand account of
two mass graves in syria this is his
first u.s television interview the
regime is a tyrannical regime
and i fear for my family because of
ongoing security threats we agreed to
shield his identity he's known only as
the gravedigger twice a week multiple
trailer trucks would come in each truck
would have
upwards of 100 to 400 or more bodies
that voice you're hearing is the
gravediggers translator moaz mustafa who
runs an advocacy group the syrian
emergency task force they were tortured
to death you could see clearly the signs
of torture on their bodies you're
describing a system
of mass murder yes absolutely this was a
systematic machinery of death the
gravedigger pointed us to this site near
the syrian capital these satellite
images obtained by cbs news show its
transformation from a barren field to a
series of trenches everything that was
going on the mass graves were systematic
and were part of what the assad regime
wanted to do based on the gravediggers
account and other evidence in a landmark
decision last january a german court
found a former syrian colonel guilty of
crimes against humanity the gravedigger
said he knows what the russians are
capable of i see the news coming out of
ukraine
my heart
hurts because i know what russia has
done in ukraine what it can do because i
know what it's done in syria what is the
benefit of your power if you don't use
it for good syrian refugee omar
al-shoghri blends in with his fellow
undergrads at georgetown university you
know when i was in jail i never thought
i would make it out
which is remarkable given this picture
from 2015 after omar spent three years
in syrian detention here you have like
the cigarette burn omar described
physical and emotional torture telling
us the regime kept meticulous records of
the prisoners who died around him i
numbered 100 buddies if not thousands of
buddies how do you emotionally survive
that this you know
human part of you disappears
in order for yours for you to survive
seven years after his mother helped him
escape from syria omar is now an
advocate for human rights
[Music]
and last month he reunited with his
sister showing us it's possible to
thread the needle of despair and stitch
together hope and purpose i can cry for
a hundred thousand years for what i went
through it wouldn't even be enough right
but i am going to tell everyone to tell
the story of the syrian people through
me
while the evidence is overwhelming and
in plain view the syrian president has
consistently denied crimes against his
own people this mirrors putin's strategy
in ukraine his spokesman has
categorically rejected the allegations
of war crimes lad
stitching together open purpose
catherine thank you very much